the Joe Rogan experience he's a guy that
I feels underappreciated Nate Marquardt
when he was at the very top of his game
was a [ __ ] assassin a Marco oh that
knockout tyron woodley in Strikeforce to
this day is one of the nastiest in tight
elbow combination knockouts I think I've
ever like a videogame knockout cz
Nate Marquardt was one of those guys I'm
like ah man you'll get anxiety before
training in practice because you knew it
was gonna be a hard goal like my
training going going
growing up in the sport was just it was
difficult man you know train with GSP
Keith Jardine Nate Mark or Joey Villa
senior Mike Van Arsdale
and you know even ali abdul aziz is even
up in the mix too but it was you know it
was it was training with guys who like
it was hard go all the time you know and
and Nate was one of those guys then I'm
just like oh my gosh this dude is not
gonna get tired unit upside he's good
everywhere he's super strong it was just
like one of those one of those when I
was like alright I gotta bring it in
order to compete today yeah he was in
that he he had this weird transition
between the UFC and Strikeforce or
people kind of forgot about him and then
when he came back to the UFC you know he
had some grilled good fights but he had
already had a really long career yeah
he'd already had some really tough
fights and then really tough fights and
training too right yeah yeah and that's
the thing like back then we weren't
really too too smart like Greg will kill
us in training like we do some [ __ ] that
you'd be like oh my gosh like one time
Greg had us doing like somebody carries
we're on a side of the Sandia Mountains
and there's like you know it's like two
or three feet and you'll fall to like
your death and then we had to do like
these buddy carry these wedding carriers
where I'm holding keep like this it's a
[ __ ] yeah and yeah this you fall to
your death like if you if you make a
mistake you know there wasn't much room
for mistake if I would have fell down
and we would have we would have fell but
you take and we had to rotate every
sixty steps
[ __ ] that and Greg and Greg was like
Greg was always on a like you know like
mental like yo you
gotta be ready to die you gotta be ready
to face death let's let's get it seek
death meanwhile he's such a sweetie in
the corner I know when the corner is hey
how you doing Rashad my gosh things are
looking great that's why he does it
because he knows we do did you in
training I can't imagine that buddy
carries a wedding carry like that and
you're literally if you fall you die you
die yeah and then it was like one little
slip and he's like alright let's change
things up go on his back and I'm like
what yeah [ __ ] out of here Greg you go
on his back [ __ ] what are you doing
what are you talking about yeah it's so
crazy it was crazy man but that was a
that was a good time there's mental
toughness training huh yeah that was a
mental toughness training well you guys
thought Albuquerque team was always
known for having crazy endurance I mean
that had to come from some of that grit
had to come from those Hill workouts
yeah we had a lot of grit because those
workouts that we did we did one where we
do the sand dunes
mmm worse and you you cry like you had
to carry somebody up doing the sand
dunes and then if you didn't carry them
all the way up then you had to do it
again until you compete as he completed
it like you were like you would
literally see grown-ass men crying just
like that's a good way to get injured
too though unfortunately yeah it's like
there's this fine line between pushing
really hard and [ __ ] somebody up yeah
you know yeah I think now they've kind
of figured it out but just the mental
aspect it paid off big dividends like
I'll talk to Dana White and Dan like bro
you are so [ __ ] crazy back then you
were so paranoid I'm like Dana White
impression paranoid back then I mean I
mean I was a fighter man fighters are
always paranoid you have to be paranoid
if you a fighter you have to think that
everybody is trying to take something
from you it's just it's just a mindset
but he'll say I was crazy I was paranoid
cuz I didn't really trust them back then
but I'm just he's a promoter right and
and then and then on top of that you
know you had you had great Greg Greg
Jackson always telling you like you know
that they wanted they want to get you
out of it man they want to get you out
the UFC
go ahead and just go ahead and just just
quit Evans just quit right now I mean I
know you want to give up they want to
get you out of here anyways man like no
no I ain't gonna quit you're not gonna
quit I don't want to see it
let's go Jesus Christ yeah it's um else
a good time over there
[Applause]